MARY KOES: Welcome
to our session
on Designing for
Observability on Google Cloud.
Charles and I will be
your hosts for today.
We are both product
managers in Cloud Logging.
So before we talk about how
to design for observability,
let's take just a moment to
talk about what observability is
and why we care.
The concept of
observability actually
comes from control theory, where
it's a really important concept
because a system can only be
controlled if it's observable,
meaning that you can
understand the internal states
from the external outputs.
It's a concept we use every
day in our thermostats, car
dashboards, and more.
For cloud computing,
observability
ties directly to
reliability and helps
us answer questions like,
what's this code actually doing?
Is my system healthy?
Where is my system
having problems?
What changed?
How can I improve my performance
and even reduce my spend?
So the three things you'll
need for observability
are logs, metrics, and traces.
Since observability can
require a lot of data,
you'll also need a system
to store and organize
all this data.
Fortunately, we've got that
part covered in Google Cloud
by using the same planet-scale
platform that we use internally
at Google to power cloud
logging and monitoring.
I frequently get
asked by customers
if they can send a few hundred
terabytes of logs per day.
We measure volumes
in quadrillions
of metrics in exabytes of logs.
And now, Charles will tell
us how to get started.
CHARLES BAER: Let's
talk through an example
to highlight the
observability needs
of the organization
of the product
and how it helps
you meet that needs.
Imagine that you are in
charge of the DevOps or SRE
team at the company and you
just started using Google Cloud.
This is a new technology for
your organization and you
professionally, though you've
worked with other cloud service
providers.
Your job is to develop
the observability plans
for the infrastructure
and applications.
While every
organization is unique,
there may be common cases
across organizations.
Where specific requirements
may be a bit different,
you can tailor your usage
to meet those needs.
First, there's a
development use case.
In our example company,
different teams
run a diverse set
of applications.
Monitoring the applications
and infrastructure
is handled by the
DevOps or SME team.
Troubleshooting is
an important use case
and used to find and fix
application infrastructure
issues.
And the last use
case is compliance.
Many companies and organizations
have compliance requirements.
Now, let's take a look at
our example, Google Cloud
infrastructure.
Our cloud environment
supports different teams
in different environments--
dev, staging,
implied environments--
with multiple projects
all centralized within a
single GCP organization.
There are also custom-developed
application servicing end users
and there are custom and
standard business-level
applications for internal
organizational users.
The environment includes
realtime analytics
and running in
Pub/Sub and BigQuery.
It's a fairly
standard enterprise
for setup on Google Cloud.
To design and build
observability for Google Cloud,
you need a few
[INAUDIBLE] items.
First, you need to collect
the logs and metrics.
Metrics and logs allow you to
build dashboards and alerting
for your monitoring and
troubleshooting use cases.
If you can instrument
your applications,
you can add support
for tracing, which
allows you to see
the performance
and optimize your
application across services.
Once you collect the logs
and the metrics and traces,
you then need a tool that
will help you interpret
those signals, which
addresses all the use
cases-- the developer,
monitoring, troubleshooting,
and compliance.
This is exactly what the
Google Cloud operation
suite provides to you.
And now, there's an
exciting new feature
in Cloud Logging in the
cloud operation suite
that we'd like to
share with you.
MARY KOES: Thanks, Charles.
So one of our key
goals for observability
is being able to ask
questions and find answers.
And to do that, you often need
the data to be stored together.
It's one of the reasons that
our architecture uniting
cloud monitoring, logging, and
trace into the cloud operations
suite is so powerful.
Well, since we launched the
Cloud Logging router last fall
to give transparency
and control over
the logs you want to
keep for observability,
and also to build an open
ecosystem for our partners,
we've gotten great feedback
from our users and partners.
We've heard that you love being
able to use log syncs to send
data to different destinations,
and exclusions to fine
tune that volume of data.
But we've also heard that
you'd like that same ability
to send logs to Cloud Logging
in a different project
so that you can centralize
your logs within Cloud Logging.
We're really excited
to announce today
a number of new log
management features
that can help improve
your observability,
starting with
expanded functionality
for the logs router.
You can now use the full
power of the logs router,
send logs from Projects
A and B to Project C,
including setting up a sync
at the folder or org level
so that all the child
projects are inherited.
This is really great for
security applications.
We do this by
introducing log buckets
as a first-class
storage solution.
Using log buckets, you can
centralize or subdivide
your logs based on your needs.
From the name, log
buckets may look
like cloud storage buckets.
But they're built on
the same logging tech
stack that we've been using to
deliver your logs in real time,
including advanced indexing and
optimizations for timestamps.
Log buckets also allow
you to take advantage
of advanced management
capabilities, including
customer retention, which we've
just made generally available,
and also newly launched
regionalization to log buckets.
One of my favorite things about
log buckets and the expanded
logs router functionality is
that we preserve that great
in-context experience, and we do
magic behind the scenes to look
up where your logs are stored so
you can still view those logs--
for your Kubernetes
cluster, for example--
right in the GKE
console in Project A
even if they're stored
centrally in Project C.
Finally, for more
advanced users,
we're also introducing
log views to allow
you to subdivide access to
logs within a log bucket.
So, for example, Charles
may centralize the logs
from all of these
projects but only
grant me access to
logs from Project A
while he can search
across all logs.
Charles, over to you to show how
to pull all of this together.
CHARLES BAER: Thank you, Mary.
Our design approach
is an iterative one,
starting with what's
provided and progressing
through the in-depth
configuration.
A great place to start is
the out-of-the-box logs
and metrics.
Cloud Logging collects all of
your logs in cloud services,
and even auto logs
so you know what's
going on in the platform.
For Compute Engine, if you need
additional application logs,
you can install agents
to collect those logs.
Cloud monitoring,
similarly, collects metrics
from all the cloud
services by default
so you can build
dashboards and learning.
When you need
additional application
or business-level metrics, you
can use those custom metrics
to monitor those over time.
Once you're using the
out-of-the-box metrics
and logs, you may find that you
need specific application logs
or business metrics.
You can collect those by using
logging and monitoring agents.
Next, you can customize
your experience,
and you can do that by using
logs-based metrics, which
can translate your log
messages into metrics.
Then you can use those metrics
to create specific learning
based on your
observability requirements
for your environment.
Now, with all of that
done, the next challenge
is doing so at scale.
Cloud Logging and
monitoring both provide
ways to aggregate
your logs and metrics.
With monitoring workspaces,
you can group your projects
into a single place and
monitor all of your projects
in a centralized location.
With logs router, log
buckets, and log views,
that Mary mentioned, you
can direct all of your logs
to a centralized project
or set of projects.
Now, if we go back
to our example,
I'll demo the step by step,
the set of best practices
in cloud logging and monitoring.
First, I'll show you what
logging and monitoring provides
out of the box.
To build observability,
you need to start
with a collection of logs
and metrics that you need.
First, I'll show you
the logs and metrics
that cloud monitoring and Cloud
Logging collect out of the box.
Let's start with
Cloud Monitoring.
Cloud Monitoring automatically
collects infrastructure
and service-level metrics.
Out-of-the-box Cloud Monitoring
drives the summary view
of your environment.
Here, you can see the incidents,
the charts, dashboards,
and your uptime check.
First, let's take a look
at one of the default
dashboards, the VM instances.
This newly refreshed dashboard
provides a high level view
of your VM instances.
Here, you can see
a detailed view
of all the instances
in your environments
along with useful
details about each.
In this particular
GCP environment,
you'll see several app
servers, a GKE cluster,
a Jenkins VM for CICD,
two Minecraft servers,
and a web development server.
Now, we're running
these Minecraft servers
because we happen to like
Minecraft, and it's fun.
And also, it's a great
example of running a Java app
on instance, because
Minecraft-- the version that
we're running--
is actually running on Java.
So we think this
is a fun example.
And it's the same
type of experience
you have running any enterprise
Java app analytic server.
Now, the Overview tab provides
a quick reference and set
of charts.
And each of the tabs
provides useful information
about your fleet of VMs.
Going back to the
Inventory tab, you'll
notice that some of the VMs have
additional memory utilization
information.
This is provided
by the monitoring
agent, which collects
additional information.
To get a sense of the additional
information that's collected,
first, let's look at
the Minecraft Server
2, which doesn't have the
monitoring agents installed.
Notice that there's
information about the instance,
and there's a default
set of charts that
are available for the instance.
Now, let's go look and
see what information
is provided for
the first instance,
clicking on Minecraft Server 1.
Notice that there are now a set
of processes that are listed
for the instance as well.
So these are all
the processes that
are running on the instance.
And the second thing to notice
is that we have an agent
up here.
And the agent provides
additional set
of charts and dashboards
around memory utilization,
disk utilization, and
detailed CPU information.
What's useful is that you
can start without the agent.
And then whenever you need
this process-level information
or the granular
memory information,
you can install the agent.
I'll show you how to do
this later in the demo.
Next, I'll show you the
out-of-the-box logging
experience.
Cloud logging
automatically collects
your platform logs and your
admin activity audit logs.
The Logs Viewer
gives you the ability
to search across your logs
and provides a query builder
to help you build your queries.
This is the new Logs
Viewer experience
that we're using
today, which includes
useful updates,
including the Logs Field
Explorer and the histogram.
The Logs Field Explorer
helps you easily
refine your search by
picking out top level fields
and values that you can
easily add to your queries.
When you select a GCE
instance resource type,
the query runs, and
the Logs Field Explorer
is updated with a
subset of the results.
The histogram helps
you gain insights
into the frequency of the
log entries over time,
and jump to the specific
logs for a given time window.
Both the Logs Field Explorer
and the histogram may be closed
and added back via
the page layout.
OK, so let's take a
look at some logs.
First, we'll look
at an audit log.
You can easily
refine your search
to find the audit logs
using Log Field Explorer
and selecting the audit
logs that are listed here.
Cloud Logging collects audit
logs for your services, which
include admin activities.
This captures the who
did what, where, and when
for your Google Cloud services.
OK.
So now that you have the
logs through admin activities
for the VM instance
within the project, first,
we can look for the first
operation in the audit log.
And you can match the entries
for the particular request
by looking at the
particular operation
and then clicking to
show matching entries.
Now, we have all the audit logs
for this particular request.
Next, we can see
who made the request
by looking at the proto
payload and looking
at the authentication fields.
So we'll expand the log and
look at the authentication
information.
Next, you can see
who made the request
by looking at the proto
payload and the request type.
Here, we can see that it
is compute instances stop.
So in addition to audit logs,
logging also captures your logs
from GCP services.
What isn't collected,
though, by default,
are logs written to specific
log files or the syslog.
To provide this
flexibility, though, you
can install the logging
agents to collect your syslogs
and adjust your
application logs.
You can see an example
of these application logs
by clearing your query filter
and leaving the GC instance,
and then selecting, for
example, the Minecraft logs.
We select a log entry
and then expand it,
and see all the details
for the specific log entry,
including the metadata, as
well as the data generated
from the application itself.
These logs are
application-specific
and created by the
Java app, which can
be collected using the agent.
Next, I'll show you how
you can install the agents
and collect the additional
log and metrics.
Now let's take a look.
In our example, we saw
that Minecraft Server 1 had
the monitoring and
logging agents installed,
and Minecraft Server 2 didn't.
The agents are built by Google
on top of the open source
Fluentd and then
collect D projects.
So let's install
the agents and start
collecting Minecraft logs.
First, we'll start with
the monitoring agent.
This will just take a
minute, and then we'll
move on to the logging agent.
Great.
Now, we'll install the
logging agents as well.
And you can find
the instructions
to install these agents
directly on our documentation.
Once they're done,
we'll check to make sure
that the logging agents have
been successfully installed
and start it using
the service command.
So there is the
Stackdriver agent,
which is the monitoring agent.
And then we'll look
at the Fluentd agent,
which is the logging agents.
Both of them are
running successfully.
Now, for fun, we'll
also customize the logs
that the Fluentd agent collects
to specifically collect
the Minecraft log
from the instance.
And so to do that, we will
use a specific configuration
file that I have
created, and we will then
copy that to the directory
that contains the Fluentd
configuration.
And then we will
restart the agent
and we'll wait for
that to restart.
Now that it's restarted,
we'll take a look
at the configuration
file that I use.
The first thing
to notice here is
the path to the log, which
is the Minecraft log here.
And the next thing
to notice is the tag
that we give it, which
is the Minecraft log.
And this is the entry that
will appear in Cloud Logging.
In this example, we're
doing something fun,
like running a Minecraft server.
However, these are
the same requirements
that you have when you're
running your own application
or instance with your
own enterprise software.
To show how logging is
collecting the logs,
I'll show a command to the
Minecraft instance that
will appear in the
logs, and then I
can find that command in
the newly tailed logs.
So enter the Minecraft server,
and I will set the time to 0.
And once I do that, I
can exit the server here.
Now that we have the
process and memory
metrics from the monitoring
agent and assist logs
and the Minecraft
logs for the agent,
now I'll show you the
logs in the viewer.
This time, I'll use
the query builder
to query for my virtual machine.
So here, I'll scroll down
to find the VM instance
and I'll look for the
Minecraft 2 server here.
There it is.
And then I'll add
that to my query.
I'll run my query, and then
I'll use the Logs Field
Explorer to hone in on the
specific Minecraft logs here.
So there we see,
if we scroll down,
we actually see the time
that we've set to 0.
So if I expand this log,
I can show you the fields.
Very similar.
You can see that it's coming
from the Minecraft 2 server,
and it contains the same
text that I had just entered.
So now you can see that we have
Minecraft logs, the Minecraft 2
server, and the message
that we've entered.
And we've collected that
using the logging agent.
Next, I'll show you how you
can customize your environment
by creating log-based
metrics and alerting.
Now, that we've collected
all of our logs,
let's start making them
actionable with custom metrics
and alerting.
I'll show you how to create
a logs-based metric based
on the count of the messages
from the application.
For the example, I'll
count the number of times
that the server saves the game.
This should be a regular
process and log entry.
If there are no logs from
the process over time,
then that should trigger a
check on the application server.
Starting Logs Viewer, let's
add the specific query
to return the logs that
we're interested in.
Next, we'll click on the Action
and then click Create Metric.
This will load the
logs-based metric UI.
We can give the metric
a name, and then we
can create the metric.
Now once we've done that, we
can actually click on the metric
that we just created here,
and we can view the logs.
We can view the metric
in the metric explorer
to see the details.
And we even create an
alert from that metric.
So first, why don't we
look at another metric
that I've created
previously, since we just
started correcting this one,
and we'll look at the Metrics
Explorer for this entry.
So this is the Metric Explorer.
This is the interface you
use in Cloud Monitoring
if you would like to do ad hoc
analysis over your metrics.
So now we can see the regular
occurrence of the metric
over time.
This metric is useful for
dashboards and ad hoc analysis.
On top of that, we
can create an alert
to alert us whenever the
specific condition happened.
I'll show you how
to do that now.
We can go back to
the login console,
and we can look at
the logs-based metrics
that we have that we
created just a moment ago.
And then we can create an
alert for the specific metric.
In this case, I
will use the metric
that I created previously--
create an alert for metric.
And this will allow me to
specify the conditions here.
So I will specify
the right aggregator.
So this helps me identify
the values of the metric
that I'd like to use.
And we can say is below two
over a given threshold of time.
In this case, we'll use six
hours as our time frame.
We will save the alert here.
This will ask us
to name the alert.
And then we have the option of
adding a notification channel,
such as an email or
any of the options
here, whether those be
Slack or SMS or a webhook,
or even Cloud Pub/Sub.
I won't add a
notification channel here.
We also have the ability
to add documentation.
Once you do that,
you've saved your alert.
So while we're having fun
with the Minecraft example,
the same process applies
to monitoring the errors
from your application
or the ProQuest volume
or the CPU utilization
for your instances.
Next, I'll show you how you
can centralize your logging
and monitoring.
Now that we have
collected all of our logs
and we've built alerting to
customize our environment,
the next step is to centralize
both logging and monitoring.
You'll likely have
more than one project,
and centralized
logging and monitoring
makes it easier to find
them, makes it easier
to satisfy operations
use case, and even
meet your compliance
requirements.
Log centralization is provided
by the new feature that Mary
mentioned, logging buckets.
The logging storage sections
contains the logging buckets,
which is a logical container for
your logs inside your logging
project.
In this case, I'd like to send
all of my logs for the three
projects in my organization
to this centralized logging
project.
To do that, I've
created a single bucket
called All Production Logs
to hold my logs for all three
projects.
And the way that the logs
are delivered to this project
is through a logging sync.
So now, I will show
you the logging sync
in the other project, which
delivers the logs to this one.
Here, this is the original
project I was showing you.
And now we have a logging
sync, which essentially takes
all of the logs that is
specified based on your logging
sync, and sends them to the
destination that you select.
In this case, we
are sending them
to the logs in the
central logging project
under All Production Logs.
And if we look at
the sync itself,
we can see that I have it
sending it to Cloud Logging.
Here is the
particular destination
in the other project.
We have not added any filter,
so all logs will be sent.
And then we have not opted any
logs out of the filter as well.
So this will generate logs
in our centralized logging
project.
So let's go take a look at the
logs in our centralized logging
project.
So once I have the logs
in a centralized place,
I can issue queries
across all the logs.
But first, I have to refine
the scope of the query
and select the appropriate
logging bucket.
I can do that by using
the refined scope
and then selecting the
scope by storage, and then
a centralized logging bucket,
and then clicking Apply.
For example, if I select
the Kubernetes details,
I can see all of the
Kubernetes resources
within the MS demo app,
including the namespaces
and the pod names.
When I select the
VM instances, I
can see all of the logs that
are generated from the instances
across all three
of the projects.
Now for the
centralized monitoring,
I'll go back to the
Monitoring Summary page
and show you the settings.
In monitoring, there's a
concept of a workspace, which
can monitor multiple projects.
I've added each of these three
projects into the workspace.
Now by doing so, I can
aggregate monitoring
across any of the
metrics in the projects.
I can create dashboards,
alerting, uptime checks
for any of the metrics captured
in any of the projects.
And that's it.
Now, we've got all of our
logs and all of our monitoring
metrics in the same place.
With this configuration,
you can search
across your project logs.
You can aggregate metrics
in your dashboards
for all of your projects.
I started out by showing you
the out-of-the-box metrics
and the logs collected by Cloud
Monitoring and Cloud Logging.
Next, I added agents to
collect the additional metrics
and logs.
Then I customized for my own
observability requirements
by building a log-based
metric and associated load.
Lastly, I configured all three
projects in my organization
to collect logs
into a single bucket
and send that to a
single workspace.
We built a baseline
for observability,
which can be extended
by instrumenting
your code for distributed
tracing and performance
optimization.
To learn more about
how the Cloud Ops
suite can help you develop
observability for your systems,
please check out other
Cloud Ops sessions.